a primera hora de este lunes 7 de marzo
la corte internacional de justicia con
sede en la ciudad neerlandesa de la daia
dio inicio a la primera jornada de la
audiencia especial que fue convocada
para escuchar el alegato presentado por
el gobierno ucraniano por genocidio en
contra de rusia tras el inicio de las
operaciones militares desde el pasado 24
de febrero en territorio ucraniano el
juez delegado para el desarrollo de esta
diligencia judicial es y fraude quien
desde el inicio de la jornada lamentó
que finalmente rusia decidiera no enviar
a ningún representante para el
desarrollo de la diligencia y recordó
que mañana 8 de marzo se espera que
rusia pudiera controvertir lo presentado
por ucrania esta audiencia se da en
virtud de la convención que busca
prevenir y sancionar el genocidio y lo
que busca es determinar medidas
preventivas por petición de ucrania para
frenar el conflicto en territorio
ucraniano